joining us now Sean Duffy former
congressman and co-host of fox
businesses the bottom line Sean this is
how it always goes is it not you know
the politician like Federman or his
handlers they need a story to get out so
they give one person access and then
they say okay tell that story for more
access in the future
Right Said the New York Times cover for
fetterman who's stuck in a hospital at
Walter Reed and just to be clear Laura I
mean in this cover piece which is all
disinformation for 12 hours a day
members of Congress or Senators they
spend time meeting with constituents
they they vote on the on the senator
house floor they go to hearings they ask
questions they caucus with their
colleagues to strategize and plan
together those are all jobs that only a
senator can do a chief of staff can't do
that but Laura in this article by the
New York Times They went so far as to
say that the chief of staff will
actually co-sponsor legislation and tell
the member of Congress after if my if my
chief of staff ever signed a piece of
legislation that I didn't approve he'd
be fired that doesn't happen anywhere
maybe in Dianne Feinstein's office but
no other office does that happen whether
you're a Democrat or Republican the
member leaves the office they're the
heart of the office they even they even
said listen the member of Congress just
kind of glad hands in some ways meetings
but the real work is done by the chief
of staff listen members of Congress sit
down for 20 30 minutes a meeting because
they want to know what their
constituents care about what their
issues are and that was a good you know
good for policy but it's good politics
Fetter men can't do any of these things
he's only a nameplate on a senate office
but with him not there a chief of staff
Who Was Not Elected cannot replace John
Federman so the the citizens of
Pennsylvania aren't being represented
right now well I think that's the key
point and we are we wish everybody well
I mean we wish him well in his recovery
I we hope everybody's you know feeling
better and getting better but he was
pushed to be in this race by looks like
his wife and a few others they knew he
wasn't you know come on they knew he
wasn't up up for it he struggled in
every day he was out on that campaign
Trail I actually felt bad for him and
he's a total leftist but I felt bad for
him but now we're seeing you know what
happens and the consequences as you said
Sean I mean Congressman for the people
the people are suffering now and there's
no leadership
it's a really good point and by the way
you mentioned his wife who pushed him to
run Rachel and I did a podcast from the
kitchen table where we talked about Joe
uh Joe Biden and Giselle fetterman and I
mean the fact that in this article she
stops by and sees him Laura one time a
week I mean Rachel would be there I mean
every other day if not every day I mean
what's going on in this family why are
we pushing so hard for our own personal
achievement as opposed to what we're
supposed to this is supposed to be
service if you can't serve the people
that you represent you should step aside
and let someone else do it and no doubt
he can't serve the people and again I
wish him well I want him to get better I
disagree with him politically but as a
human being and as a father I want him
to recover but you can't represent uh
your constituents as a senator so let
someone else do it
uh Sean we appreciate it thank you so
much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else